em maio de 2013 eu fui uma palestra na
universidade federal de santa catarina
ele estava divulgando a oportunidade de
intercâmbio social da puc 163
intercambistas falando um tiro pra
áfrica um tinha ido pra índia é outra
mina pelo leste europeu e muitas
histórias que eles contaram que eram tão
incríveis e deixaram então maravilhado
que fizeram questionar o momento que
está vivendo a minha vida eu tinha
acabado de me informar a administração
tinha voltado para o direito que estava
na sétima fase eu já trabalhava oito
horas por dia e ainda assim do ponto de
vista académico profissional me sentia
bem mas sabe se que no fundo algo
faltava experiência de vida como aquelas
que faltava
comecei a pensar nos locais que eu tinha
interesse de viajar minha dúvida
principal é entre a ásia ea áfrica
eu comecei a conversar com alguns amigos
para saber aonde chão ele que ele tinha
achado duas amigas que tinha ido porque
nem vieram conversar comigo e não
contavam com tanta paixão que tanta
emoção é com tanta nostalgia tarde que
ela tinha vivido por lá
eu simplesmente assim com certeza vão me
bater se eu pensasse em escolher outro
lugar mas principalmente porque eu
queria sentir na própria pele ver com os
próprios olhos se tudo aquilo que ela
falava na verdade
lembro que na época o mais difícil foi
pedir demissão meu chá que achou que eu
tinha virado rip que eu ia largar tudo
pra fazer voluntariado na áfrica
mas enfim a decisão estava tomada eu me
demitir um dia no outro como a passagem
pra não ter mais volta
em julho o embarque rumo ao quênia é
assim que eu cheguei a viagem só pra te
ver isso aqui é uma aventura tudo já
começou a acontecer no primeiro dia a
companhia perdeu uma mala boa
depois a pessoa que foi buscar não foi
buscar
eu fiquei quatro horas no aeroporto
perdido sozinho a casa que eu ia não
existia mais eu acabei indo pra outra
casa e tudo isso foi no primeiro dia mas
também eu queria uma aventura país que
eu tava lá eu encarei de frente
nairobi para minha surpresa
melhor dizendo pra minha ignorância era
uma cidade muito rica tinha bmw na rua
hotel cinco estrelas até a churrascaria
brasileira clarice mas vamos lá
a realidade na realidade estereótipo que
a gente tem na nossa cabeça que é a
áfrica
no primeiro dia de aula lembro que
acordei bem cedo às 7 horas da manhã saí
de casa com mais dois amigos chineses o
bananinha doce
a gente entrou no matatu é uma vã assim
que vamos 16 pessoas na parte de trás
bem apertadas com música alta tem umas e
até a luz neon a festa assim o super
recomendo para quem foi um dia para a
europa tenha pelo menos uma vez no
matatu dar mais ou menos uma hora até a
chegada à favela eu acho que é assim que
a gente chegou
o que mais chamou atenção foi a sujeira
lá eles não têm saneamento básico nenhum
jogo é nenhum
eles fazem essas grandes montanhas de
lixo e colocavam fogo de uma espécie de
brasa tá
e essa montanha de lixo queimamos subir
aquele cheiro horrível aí uma fumaça
tóxica pelo ar sem falar de toda a
poeira que já tinha por que não era nada
asfaltado em alguns locais da favela
lá quem não tem dinheiro que a maioria
para arcar com os banheiros privados
fazem todas as necessidades em sacos
plásticos e joga pela janela então
alguns locais era o cheiro e
simplesmente insuportável e aí já foi o
primeiro grande aprendizado eu lembro
que a gente voltando pra casa a gente
questionou como é que a gente vai passar
oito semanas trabalhando aqui todo dia e
só no primeiro dia a gente quase passou
mal umas três vezes o primeiro
aprendizado foi a quebra de paradigma
que o ser humano é um ser extremamente
adaptável em três dias a gente estava em
casa a gente já não ligava pro cheiro já
andava qualquer lugar já sabia aonde
evitar o cheiro era muito ruim e
realmente esse foi o primeiro grande
aprendizado
a princípio foi parar na europa para a
aula de inglês matemática para crianças
de 5ª a 8ª série e para ajudar na
construção de uma escola que a gente
arrecadar um dinheiro aqui no brasil
o primeiro grande desafio é ser
professor é dividir uma sala de
aproximadamente uns 20 metros quadrados
com mais dois professores eram três
turmas na mesma sala sem nenhuma
divisória
eu tentava às vezes é aluno de cursinho
fazer uma dinâmica uma piada com os
alunos é impossível que o chamava
atenção de todos os alunos das outras
turmas já na estação super complicado
pois os professores
eu tinha que também me adaptar ao país e
lá o professor tem uma autoridade muito
forte sobre os alunos e muitas vezes
eles batiam os alunos eu tinha que ficar
simplesmente quero absorver aquilo
aceitar que a cultura não podia fazer
nada a respeito
então isso tudo realmente se mostrou
muito difícil pra mim eu comecei a aula
e depois de uma semana dando aula a
gente teve uma escola para construir a
escola nova
a gente se mudou para um pede que a
gente já comprado e pago posteriormente
uns 500 metros de distância a expressjet
uma estrutura bem melhor
tinha uma sala de aula para cada turma
mas ele mostrou um problema novo que a
gente não tinha reparado antes as alas e
não consistirá em sua própria mão
essa favela eu trabalhava se chamava
mandar e tinha cerca de 600 mil
habitantes é uma das mais pobres de toda
a áfrica
as casas eram muito grudadas umas das
outras e em torno do sol não conseguia
passar às vezes pela tv al khansa
janeiro nada dentro das casas das salas
de aula
se já não bastasse todos os problemas
que a gente já encarava todo dia como
aluno que tá com fome porque a única vez
que ele come no colégio é um almoço à
base de batata feijão uma pasta de
amendoim no café da manhã
se não bastasse ele não tem um material
didático preparado tudo isso o aluno
conseguir enxergar o próprio caderno na
sala
eu fiquei indignado por quilo conversei
com um amigo meu egípcio que tinha o
mesmo problema na escola dele a gente
começou cara vamos tentar achar uma
solução taí luminar comunidades que não
possuem acesso à rede elétrica gente
botou no google literalmente isso a
gente achou um projeto chamado litrão
fly que em vez de eu tentar ficar aqui
explicando para vocês o que é o projeto
eu prefiro mostrar um vídeo da primeira
instalação que a gente fez foi um teste
e aí vocês vão ver os estados para que
vocês gostem
a você
ae
é como brincar
de bata
jonas
rolando
ela lê eu tô com o avô anda pegando a
mão assim como vocês o diretor da escola
parece ter gostado bastante também fala
eu andei fu panda foi no final e não só
ele e vários outros diretores de outras
escolas começaram a visitar nossa pra
ver o efeito do projeto e começar a
pedir que a gente fizesse aquilo na
escola deles infelizmente a última
semana disse uma amiga egípcio e eu tive
que começar a tocar o projeto sozinho eu
parei de dar aula porque não dava tempo
a gente passava me interpretaram as
garrafas para passar a tarde instalando
não era um projeto fácil a gente se
cortava muito e era tudo muito sujo a
gente cortar telhado de alumínio era bem
fina e outro problema era com a
alimentação a gente passava o dia
inteiro de manhã trabalhando quando subi
no telhado
é muito complicado você ficar com medo
em cima porque é um lugar muito sujo
então tens algo prático mas não tem como
se algo prático como chocolate por
exemplo eu tô em cima do telhado
branquela como estimular que mussum em
que sua rede e todas as crianças da
escola tirando isso vai tirar vai comer
chocolate cima de um telhado de uma
creche que nunca nem vi um chocolate na
vida não existe essa possibilidade nem
pra gente na alimentação era basicamente
de frutas para vocês terem uma idéia no
final das mesmas oito semanas lá eu
tinha perdido 12 quilos e 12 quilos não
era o objetivo mas enfim para quem
quiser fazer uma causa social um regime
ou super recomendo
mesmo com todas as dificuldades o
projeto foi crescendo e eu tive a
felicidade de jogar ao lado de meus
cinco melhores amigos do meu lado em
cima de um telhado em baixo e mais três
amigos ajudando a no final das minhas
oito semanas a gente tinha feito mais de
12 escolas estaduais entre 40 garrafas
inclusive no interior do quênia é
impactado a vida de aproximadamente três
mil estudantes
vocês podem perguntar
mas como você fazia isso o tempo todo o
projeto vocês que bancavam todas as
dificuldades de se cortar e da comida
como um monte de intercambistas se
juntavam para fazer
eu acho que isto causa um sentimento que
é pra tentar explicar para vocês vou
contar uma história que aconteceu na
última semana quando estava lá eu estava
realizando o maior projeto de todos que
a gente já tinha feito até o momento
era uma escola chamada spams em que
bella no maior complexo de favelas do
mundo
só nessa escola a gente colocar 48
garrafas
essa escola pronta eu estava em cima do
telhado e o tempo começou a fechar a
gente nunca trabalha na chuva eu comecei
a descer escadas juntei tudo que eu
descia a escada uma professora que já
tinha visto algumas vezes por lá me
puxou pelo braço e foi levado até a sala
de aula pra gente uma sala de aula me
levou até a mesa dela fica do lado
oposto da porta bem perto de uma lâmpada
que a gente tinha acabado de instalar a
gente chegou lá ela falou assim meu
filho é a primeira vez em quatro anos
que eu trabalho aqui que eu consigo ler
ou corrigir uma prova na minha sala de
aula
muito obrigado muito obrigado muito
obrigado
ela falou que a lei com uma naturalidade
incrível assim mas já não tinha idéia do
efeito que aquela frase ea causar em
cima de mim demorar mais ou menos uma
hora pra voltar pra casa eu estava
voltando refletir bastante sobre isso é
como que uma ajuda tão simples instalar
uma garrafa plástica no telhado pode
fazer uma pessoa ficar tão grata por
algo né
você começa a se questionar e ajuda
efêmera porque é uma garrafa dessa dura
de dois a três anos então realmente
impactar na vida de muita gente
cheguei em casa ela morava com mais 21
intercambistas
eu fico brincando que a gente ia jantar
a gente fazer uma ceia e aí eu
questionei pessoal na galera
quantas vezes no dia a dia de vocês
vocês se sentem incondicionalmente o
texto sem querer nada em troca quantas
vezes eu parei para pensar no meu dia a
dia nada semana talvez não mas também
não
a conclusão que eu acho que 24 anos de
idade eu nunca tinha de fato tira aquele
sentimento que eu tinha sentido aquele
dia com a professora
acho que é isso que juntava sabe os
alunos ali todos os intercambistas esse
projeto à espera poder desse sentimento
de utilidade é assim infelizmente era a
última semana tá voltando para o brasil
lembro bem no dia que estava no
aeroporto de joanesburgo na áfrica do
sul
escrevendo no último blog contando na
atualizando uma família sobre esses
últimos fatos
meu pai sabia muito essa preocupação
total com a preocupação de todo o
intercambista todo já viajou aqui teve
aquela idéia de voltar à velha rotina
voltar à velha vida e se ficar naquele
desespero meu pai me ligou para me
tranquilizar e falou assim filhão
fica tranquilo que o ser humano é um
produto do meio você já se acostuma
era tudo que eu não quero ouvir que eu
tinha que voltar ao meio falei meu deus
mais pois tinha acabado de ver essa
experiência eu vi quando o ser humano é
adaptável e no pragmatismo de sempre o
meu pai estava certo
assim que eu pisei no brasil entrou em
contato com laquê dias que eu sabia que
era o presidente da organização que
espalhou essa ideia por litro de leite
pelo mundo e foi lá que posso criar no
brasil o vítor não sei se você sabe mas
quem criou essa idéia da lâmpada de urna
foi um brasileiro chamado alfredo mozer
naquela onda de apagões esteve em 2002
se brasileiro criou na cidade sorocaba
fez ali na cidade dele lá que ficou
maravilhado pediu pro alfredo pra
espalhar se pelo mundo
só naquele ano nas filipinas ele fez
mais 500 mil garrafas e começou a
espalhar se pelo mundo
ele falou victor claro que você pode
mais o primeiro me mandou o material da
áfrica provável que vocês fizeram
eu mandei a gente teve a feliz notícia
que nós éramos a equipe que mais tinha
feito garrafas na áfrica até o momento
como equipe ele ele pensa em vitor teve
uma menina que já entrou em contato o
tempo atrás comigo e ela queria criar um
livro de luz no brasil
vou matar vocês dois em contato e vocês
trabalham junto foi pouco claro
e aí começa uma série de coincidências
incríveis que me trouxeram até aqui hoje
eu sou nascido em brasília essa menina
nascido no maranhão e nós dois com
incidência do destino morávamos numa
ilha chamada florianópolis
ela entrou em contato comigo no outro
dia a gente estava tomando café e aí ela
falou eu morto de curiosidade para saber
como ela conheceu o projeto e aí vem
outra coincidência incrível na minha
opinião ela conheceu esse projeto ela
foi visitar um amigo intercambista
estava na índia que é aquele mesmo
intercambista que lá no início fez
aquela parece universidade federal
incentivou muito a fazer essa viagem
oficial à áfrica e quando ela conhece
quando ela foi visitar o pedro o pedro
falou que tinha uma conferência de
energia elétrica é conhecido lá que
pessoalmente ele lá que entregou uma
bandeira do livro de luís e falou assim
pedro quando você poupa o brasil criou o
projeto a os dois voltaram ao brasil com
aquela sede de criar o projeto mas eles
nunca tinham subido no telhado na vida e
eu tinha um currículo de muitos telhados
assim que eu cheguei em questão de uma
semana a gente já tava com a nossa
equipe formada começando a trabalhar
juntos a gente viu que no brasil a gente
tem um potencial enorme dentro do livro
de luz há cerca de 2,7 milhões de
habitantes no brasil não possuem acesso
à energia elétrica segundo o último
censo do ibge
sem falar de todos aqueles que possuem
acesso à energia elétrica mas que não
têm capacidade de arcar com ela eles
podem perguntar victor mas para aí você
o pedro alana e toda sua equipe do livro
de luís você falou vocês pretendem de
alguma forma subir em todos os telhados
no mundo espalhando a idéia não a gente
não tem essa pretensão
nosso objetivo é inspirar e motivar a
ensinar lideranças locais a espalhar
essa idéia dentro das suas próprias
comunidades assim como espera de alguma
forma está fazendo aqui com pelo menos
um de vocês
afinal de contas eu o chamo sinceramente
quantas vezes no dia a dia de vocês
vocês se sentem em condicionalmente
úteis